معنى من عمنا لواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد فاز
الدويري وانت تتابع منذ الصباح ما يجري من
تطورات ميدانيه عسكريه في الخرطوم هل
تتوقع ان تطول هذه الازمه العسكريه على
مستوى المواجهات بين الطرفين
يعني الان نحن امام
مشهدين مختلفين تماما امام تصريحات
متعارضه بالمطلق امام حقيقه غائبه عن
توصيف دقيق على ما
يجري على الارض وبالتالي لا تزال الصوره
ضبابيه والمشهد
قاتم جدا لماذا لا يوجد مصدر محايد يقدم
معلومه يقينيه حول حقيقه ما يجري لو اخذنا
اي موقع من المواقع السته التي تم الاشاره
لها في هذا التقرير نجد الانباء المتضاربه
هذا يجعلنا نذهب الى باب التخمين والى باب
اعتماد الافتراضات التي تستند الى مكنون
القوه لدى طرفي الصراع والى طبيعه
المقاربه العسكريه خلال الساعات والايام
القادمه من حيث القوه العسكريه الجيش
السوداني لديه قدرات قتاليه اكثر لكن قوات
الرد السريع بانها خفيفه الحركه لديها
مرونه في التحرك لديها القدره على القتال
في المناطق المبنيه اذا الميزات التي
يتمتع بها الجيش من حيث القدره الصاروخيه
والمدفعيه وسلاح الجو يقابلها تميز لدى
قدرات الدفاع السريع
لكن هذه النقطه عفوا هذه النقطه بالتحديد
يعني كما كما نلاحظ مما يجري ميدانيا
ان المعارك او بالاحرى المواجهات تتركز في
نقاط محدده بمعنى ان الامور لم تدخل في
اطار حرب الشوارع للسيطره على شارع من
هناك او حي من هنا يعني هناك
مقرات محدده موجوده في اماكن معينه
يجري التنافس العسكري على السيطره
عليها ومن هنا الى اي مدى يمكن للدعم
السريع فعلا ان
يسيطر على هذه الاماكن المحدده دون الحديث
عن الدخول في حرب شوارع والسيطره على
احياء داخليه
يعني اذا اخذنا الاجابه على سؤالك يعني
اذا اخذنا المعلومات التي تم نشرها حول ما
يجري فيه محيط القصر الجمهوري المعلومات
التي
نشرت كان ثلاثه دبابات تم تعزيزها الى عشر
ذبابات كان يقابلها عشره اليات او عربات
دفع رباعي رفعت الى 20 وبالتالي حتى حول
الهدف الواحد لا تزال هناك ضبابيه لكن انت
اشرت الى نقطه بمنتهى الاهميه وهي القتال
حول مراكز محدده التلفزيون القصر الجمهوري
دار الضيافه المطار الى غير ذلك من يسيطر
عليها الان يستطيع ان يقول انني سيطرت
وبالتالي يكسب البعد النفسي والمعنوي
والذي يلقي بظلاله على مسار العمليات في
الساعات والايام القادمه لكن اعتقي الشخصي
ان الحسم ليس بمتناول اي من الجانبين في
خلال 24 وال 48 ساعه القادمه ما لم يحدث
تغيير معين لماذا اذا ذهبنا الى مطار مروي
في جمله واحده تم الاعلان السيطره عليهم
من قبل قوات الرد السريع لكن تم استعاده
السيطره عليه من قبل الجيش قبل ساعتين من
الان كان هناك عن حديث عن احتمال هجوم
جديد لقوات الرد السريع بعد وصول تعزيز
نعم الدعم السريع اذا دعني اقول الموقف
يمكن ان يوصف بالحرب المائه التي لا تعطي
اشارات من الذي
فايز كنت كنت تشير الى نقطه مهمه جدا وهي
موازين القوى بين الطرفين ما الذي يملكه
الجيش وما الذي يملكه الدعم السريع الان
بخبر عاجل امامنا نقلا عن مصادر يفيدنا
مراسل الجزيره انه
ان سلاح الجو
هذا او بالاحرى استهدف سلاح الجو معسكررا
في ضاحيه صالحه بي ام درمان وهذا المعسكر
تابع لقوات الدعم السريع يعني استناد
الجيش الى سلاح الجو الان في هذه
المواجهات بعدما كانت دعم السريع قال انه
تم تحييد سلاح الجو ويبدو ان الامر ليس
صحيحا كما تشير اليه الانباء الى اي مدى
يعطي الجيش افضليه هنا
يا سيدي الجيش لديها اوراق قوه اكثر من
الحسم السريع بناء على طبيعه القوات يوجد
لديه تقريبا بحدود 80 طائره ما بين طائره
هجوميه وطائره مقاتله يوجد لديه 25 مدفع
ذات الحركه ويوجد لديه ما يقارب 400 مدفع
مجرور يوجد لديهم منظومه صواريخ اذا دعني
اقول في موازين القوى الامور تسير لصالح
القوه الجيش السوداني السيطره على الاهداف
الرئيسيه يسير لصالح الجيش السوداني
احتماليه تنجير معسكرات للرد السريع يسير
لصالح الجيش الجيش السوداني لكن التخوف في
هذا الحاله واستنادا الى الموروث التاريخي
في الصراعات التي دارت مع الحركات المسلحه
في السودان ان تتحول الى ما يشبه الحرب
الاهليه ان تتحول الى حرب الشوارع هنا
تنتفي الميزات التي يتمتع بها الجيش يعني
اذا ما في بعض
العاجله ان هناك الكفاء للقوات الرد
السريع باتجاه الاحياء المدنيه هنا لا
يمكن استخدام المدفعيه لا يمكن استخدام
الطائرات ولا حد عموديه اذا يعني اقول
المقالات مفتوحه ولكن هل لدى الجيش القدره
على تحييد المعسكرات العلنيه والسريه لانه
يوجد معسكرات سريه في منطقه خرطوم بحري
طيب سيد فايز يعني ما ما
اهميه القتال داخل الشوارع والاحياء ما
اهميتها عسكريا اذا لم تكن فقط
لمطارده الهاربين والمختبئين داخل هذه
الاحياء بما ان المساله تحسم في المقرات
الرئيسيه والسيطره عليها
يا سيد يعني الان ما هي اعداد القوات للرد
السريع في المنطقه الحديث في هذا المساء
هذا اليوم عن نقل ما يقارب 20,000 اي
التعزيزات التي خلال ال 24 ساعه 20 الف
القوات الرد السريع مئه الف الجيش
الجيش السوداني الفاعل 105 الاف اذا هناك
توازن من حيث اعداد القوه البشريه مع
اختلاف التسليح انت تشير الى نقطه قاتله
جدا لا نتمنى ان تذهب الاحداث باتجاهها
وهي قتال الشوارع هنا تختلف المعادله كليا
هنا يصبح القتال اكثر دمويه هل يرقى الى
مستوى القتال على سبيل المثال فيما يجري
في بعض المدن في في ما جرى في العراق او
في سوريا او ما يجري في في غيرها من الدول
في اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال لا نتوقع ذلك
لكن دعني اقول اذا باختصر المقاربه
العسكريه اذا كانت المقاربه العسكريه
تستهدف التجمعات الرئيسيه
ونقاط التجمع لقوات الرد السريع وكان هناك
اعتماد لاسلوب المناوره بتطويق هذه
المعسكرات
محاوله منعها من التمادي في القتال قد
يكون المسار لصالح الجيش السوداني شكرا
للفيس الزويريه
حدثتنا من عمان